- [Kevin] Hello everyone.
I have a question, who here
has been woken up at 3:00 AM
to look at a log for a production outage?
Can I see a show of hands?
Is it everybody?
I see some people with hands down.
What's your secret?
Maybe you want to come up and do the talk?
I know I have.
And so what we're talking about today
is how we can use some
of our new agentic tools
to help avoid that situation.
My name's Kevin, I have
Andrea with me here today,
and we're here to talk to you about,
this is a code talk by the way.
So we're gonna talk about what
tools do we have available
and how can we build something
that helps us improve our
observability posture.
So I started working with
observability at AWS,
I think seven years ago and
the space has changed a lot.
We used to see a problem
where customers did not
have the metrics logs
and traces that they needed
to solve their problems.
Maybe a key log method was missing,
maybe distributed tracing wasn't there.
But that situation has changed
with tools like Open Telemetry
and CloudWatch being
integrated into everything.
It's easier than ever to produce
usable observability data.
Sometimes just a few clicks of a button,
sometimes, you know, one Terraform module
and all of a sudden you have
all the observability you need.
So the problem has changed.
What we see is that customers
have too much data now
to quickly solve the problems they need.
You can produce all of
the data, and traces,
and logging that you need,
but if you can't quickly solve a problem,
you're not really getting
your value for that.
And it's very exciting
because in our opinion,
AI is a really good use case for us.
And I know you hear it's a
good use case for everything,
but I think for observability,
we really do make a case
for AI and it works really good for us.
And so when we think about an agent,
I'm sure you all know most of this,
but we're essentially having
some LLM do some processing.
We're giving it a lot of context.
We're giving it a query,
and then we want it to perform
the programmatic work, right?
We want it to do SQL queries,
it to write metric insights queries,
and it to process all those values.
And we wanna see just a
natural language response.
I know that sometimes,
I would be deploying
something a long time ago
and you look and you just
see a Java stack trace
or something and you're like,
just what is this, right?
And this really helps
that problem a lot, right?
To take that and make it
natural language that is saying,
we think this is the problem,
we recommend you do this.
That's a big leap.
But the agents don't
really work great for this
unless we give them
access to the right data.
Show of hands, who here
uses MCP tools today?
I think probably a lot of you.
Great, yeah, most of you.
So at AWS we of course make a lot of them,
but this talk is not
really about that, right?
We want to think about
how we use the tools
and how we can gain extra value from them.
And what we're doing is thinking about
how our MCPs can access
these tools like CloudWatch
or Prometheus or some
type of postmortem tool.
And the MCP's job is to, one,
tell the agent what it can do,
what APIs are available, and
then maybe more importantly,
provide a security boundary
where you're saying,
my MCP tool can query Prometheus,
but I don't want 1,000 agents
on everybody's computer
directly with permissions to query.
And so, the MCP is very
important for that.
And so, how are we gonna use these?
Has anybody seen this screen before?
Has anybody done our
one observability demo?
Just, okay, you guys
should all check that out.
But essentially, what we're gonna do today
and what we're gonna build and
Andrea is gonna show you is,
we have this pet adoption
website with some very cute pets.
And these are actually real
pictures from our team,
most of them.
And, "The Pet Adoption
Clinic" is what it's called.
And you could, it's a
fictional web application
where you can go and
you could adopt a pet,
you could bring your pet to the vet,
and buy food for your pet and
all different types of things.
So when we look at this, let's
think about the data, right?
So as applications have changed,
they've become more and more distributed.
And so, each of these services
is going to produce
observability data, right?
Metrics, logs, and traces.
So maybe you used to have a monolith
where you have your logs and
your data all in one spot.
Now you have this explosion of data
because you've took one thing
and abstracted it to
maybe 50 things, right?
I have three up here, but it
could be way more for you guys
in a more complicated deployment.
And when we see that happening,
we need a way to easily analyze this.
So in our case, we're
sending it to CloudWatch,
but this could be even
other observability tools
or other data stores, the
same thing still applies.
And so, what's our strategy here?
When we build an agent,
and I think this is the
most important thing,
we need to provide it with
as much context as possible.
We wanna define SLOs, that's
a service level objective
where you're essentially telling the agent
what is important to you
and your organization.
You're saying, over the last 30 days,
I expect my application to have a latency
of 30 MS for 99% of request.
That's an example of an SLO.
And when you provide this
rich context to the agent,
you're going to get a lot more data
that is specific to you and your team.
And then we need to take that data,
we need to analyze the trends.
We need to say to our agent,
don't just look at the current state,
look around the corners, right?
What could potentially be an issue later?
And then finally,
we want to make our
agent better over time.
So let's take an example of
our pet adoption website.
And we run this agent that creates,
let's say an HTML report
of observability findings.
And we want to feed those
findings back into the agent
on each successful invocation.
That way it can get better over time.
And so, what are we gonna
actually show today?
Or what are we gonna build?
And, I promise we're
getting to code, right?
I'm not just gonna talk the whole time.
But essentially, we are starting
with a natural language query.
It could be manual
or it could be triggered
by an alarm, right?
That would be a little bit better
to have something lying in
wait and an alarm is triggered
and your agent gets to work for you.
We have our LLM and what we do
and what I think is really cool
is using the strands agent,
this is a SDK, it's open source.
You can build an agent in, I
don't know, 10 lines of code.
We're gonna show you a lot
more, not just 10 lines,
but you can get started that quickly.
It's really amazing
how quickly you can build
something interesting for you.
And then we want to provide
it with all the context
that it needs.
So we want to provide it
with our operational tenants,
with our SLOs.
We want to tell it exactly
its purpose, and its job,
and how it should do things.
And we also need to provide
it with the MCP access
so it can properly query
things and get data.
And finally, we want some
type of usable output.
So it could be an HTML report
that you send out daily
to a stakeholder.
It could be, it finds a gap
and then it creates an alarm for you.
It's very useful and we're
gonna show that in a little bit.
But the goal is to have
some type of human understandable output
from your programmatic
queries of structured data.
And I'm gonna pass it over to Andrea now.
He's gonna show you the code
and show, you what we built,
and how we think about this, and...
- [Andrea] Thank you Kevin.
All right, so before I swap the screen,
so one thing I wanna mention
is, you're gonna see a QR code
at the end of this presentation.
So all the code you're
gonna see is open source,
so you can go off download it,
but before going into
that, I wanna do a premise.
So code will run, we'll do stuff.
So make sure that if you
try modify the free stuff
like you do with your
pre-production environment,
'cause it's gonna create
artifacts as we're gonna see.
Okay, lemme say that I wanna start this
by looking at what the
agent is gonna create
after each run, all right?
So what you see on screen
is the observability report
from one run of the agent where,
what we are asking the agent to do is,
go off into my account and
find interesting stuff for me.
We can say that what
interesting stuff means,
'cause you need to steer the
agent in a very specific way
if you want it to be valuable.
So I wanna analyze that report with you
so that you can actually
see what's the outcome.
And so, we can relate that with the code
that we're gonna see in a second, okay?
So the report is split
into a different section.
The first one is the executive summary.
And so, the agent is telling us that,
we have AWS infrastructure
with mainly an EKS-based
PetSite adoption system
that Kevin mentioned before.
We have Lambda functions
and comprehensive logging.
And one interesting thing
that it's already highlighting
is that our PetSite deployment service,
there is active traffic and
there are some security scan
happening in my system.
And then the agent took the decision
to create a critical
monitoring alarms for us, okay?
So that's kind of like a TLDR
of what the agent has done, really.
So now we can actually go down
and look a little bit more in details.
So we can see we have
an alarm section here.
One says, okay, so this
system didn't have any alarm.
And so, when the agent run, he
created four critical alarms.
A PetSite, high latency,
high fault error rate,
and then a lambda duration alarm.
If you think about those,
it's quite impressive
that the agent is
interpreting what we have
into the account, understand
what are the alarms
that needs to be created
and creating them.
And we're gonna see how we did this
in a few minutes, all right?
And then definitely,
there is security scan,
again it's highlight that.
Then next, we have some key metrics
that the agent is telling us
that we should be looking at.
And you can see here we
have PetSite error rate,
PetSite fault rate, and PetSite latency.
So now interestingly, if we
go to the fault rate first,
you're gonna see we have a
low level amount of fault
is 0.07%, nothing concerning,
but something definitely
you wanna be aware of.
But most interestingly is the error rate
flat time series here.
Now, there's one thing
that in this new AI world
people used to say, which is like,
oh, I'm gonna find
something that is anomalous.
But most of the time, looking at something
that is not anomalous
is as equally important
as what is going wrong.
In this case, specifically
the agent has found out
that we have faults,
but there are no error related
to those faults, all right?
So you can see that probably
we have a level of 500 errors
but not 400, and you can
relate that with your code.
'Cause in general, they
may be related, okay?
And at the same time, agent
found out that we have a latency
of 400 milliseconds on average, roughly,
this is also not very good.
And we are gonna see it's
gonna talk about that
in a few sections here.
Then next on, we have an
operational audit review
where the agent is telling
us we have an EKS application
where we have this latency
of 402 millisecond on average
and you know, yeah, with
the last day average
and we have a link to the console
to actually go off and check it ourself.
And then fault rate and error
rate that we just saw above.
You know, and this saying to us like,
okay, 500 server errors
are still acceptable levels
'cause it's 0.06%, not bad
but definitely something to notice.
And definitely there is active traffic.
Then we have a Lambda functional analysis
where we have like few
status updated functions.
We have step functions and
we have synthetic monitoring.
How many of you know what synthetic is?
Anyone familiar with it?
Raise your hand.
Okay, for everybody that
doesn't know Synthetic is,
it's a CloudWatch service,
an AWS service that
what it does is, you can write your code
and run cannery testing, okay?
So it's a way to do full
end-to-end testing to your service.
You call your API, you expect
the result is 200, 500,
depending on what you're testing there.
And it's based on Lambda.
So it's actually saying like,
okay, so we have four end-to-end tests,
that's the way to read it.
Then sure, we have a EKS
infrastructure with a cluster,
you know, linked to the
cluster if we want to go there.
There are two gig of storage,
which is probably something interesting.
In fact, the agent also
thought that it's worth it
to think about the
CloudWatch logs analysis.
'Cause of those two gig
of storage, we have 1.36
that are just in my
application logs, right?
So some optimization costs
that we can actually look at.
Now, operational finding, this
is where the security scan
has been described a little bit more.
So the agent found out that
there were significant scan
across all those hundreds of
operations that were happening
and you know, to different
common path, right?
So PHP exploitation, admin panel probing,
there is WordPress
vulnerability and so on.
And now the agent tells us like,
what should we do, all right?
So now this section,
and we're gonna see the code
is split into like three tiers.
Like, what you should right
now, medium term, and long term.
And so immediate actions it say like,
okay, you should be enabling
AWS web application firewall
on PetSite to block all these paths,
you know, the scanning that it's happening
and review CloudTrail.
And then as part of
monitoring, there are like,
you know, there weren't
alarms remember, right?
So the agent say like,
okay, I took an action
and I created the alarms for
you and we're gonna see how.
So this is a first step
where we make the agent
to operate into our
observability artifacts,
and there should be also SLOs
into application signals.
Now, the agent haven't done this
because we haven't created the tool.
So this is an exercise for home, right?
So I'll show you how we did four alarms
and you can use the same approach
to create application signal SLOs.
And then moving forward, we
have short term improvements.
That is our 400 millisecond
latency, you know,
definitely it's something to look into.
And long term, we have a two,
almost 3% service quarter utilization.
So we can improve this by
using auto scanning policies
and things like that.
Now, one interesting part I
wanna highlight here is like,
a relation with industry create incident.
So one of the things that the
engine we're gonna build today
is gonna do is not only
going into your account
to find stuff and maybe
create some artifacts.
But, what I want when I wake
up 3:00 AM in the morning
and something is happening is like,
is what I'm saying something
that it's well known in the industry?
And that's what the agent is doing.
And if you look here, the security scan
that we seeing into this system,
they're related to WordPress
security vulnerability of 2022.
And the agent is telling
us like, what was that?
It's multiple requests to
WordPress or WordPress login.
You know, what's the industry context?
This was like a problem in 2022.
And what is the applied solution?
AWS web application firewall.
So effectively, the
agent is telling us like,
hey, this is a well-known thing
and the industry has
fixed this in this way,
go off and do it.
And it's also telling us how to do it.
Like, deploy web application firewall,
use the top 10 rule sets
and then enable CloudTrail
for API level monitoring.
And optionally, we can also set up
automated incident response
for those requests, right?
It's pretty cool.
So this just a single run of the agent
that is creating this report
and it found a few things for us.
So now, I think what I wanna do is,
I wanna show you how
the agent is doing that.
So, are you ready for some coding here?
Raise your hand.
Okay, so your laptop out,
I'm kidding you, right?
I'm gonna walk you through the code
and we're gonna see,
unfortunately we only have an hour
for this session, so I'll try my best
to walk through the most interesting code
and then, definitely as as I mentioned,
this is open source so you can go off
and download, change, and try.
Okay, so as I talk,
I'm actually starting the
agent in the terminal.
That's what you're gonna see there running
and we're gonna look at
what it's doing bit by bit,
but don't get distracted too much, okay?
Okay, so when you're gonna
download this repository,
you're gonna see a folder called
observability agent, okay?
And in this folder,
effectively, it's a Python agent
and there is a main file.
So in this main file there
is, effectively some settings
that we're using,
arguments, so effectively,
when we run the agent,
we wanna specify options,
the regions that we're gonna be using
unless we use the default.
You know, whether we want
this reporting markdown
because effectively we wanna
feed a different agent,
for example, or we want HTML
for consuming from an image,
or maybe both, right?
And then definitely if we
want some verbose there
in case you're debugging and
you wanna see what's going on.
But effectively, the most
important lines of code here
is here, line 52 and 53,
where what we're doing is,
we are creating these natural
language observability agent
and we're actually asking the
agent to run the analysis.
Okay, so now, let's go into
this observability agent.
Let's see what we're
talking about here, okay?
So a premise here, Kevin mentioned before,
we're gonna be using a strands agent
across all the code here,
and we're gonna do that
to create our tools
to use MCP servers and tools
and to create the actual agent.
So, and you're gonna see
how easy this is, all right?
So the natural language
of observability agent,
what it does here is, as an innate method
that it's loading the application setting.
So things like regions
and stuff like that.
It's not super interesting,
but it's also initializing
the MCP client manager,
which we're gonna see in a second.
That's where we gonna use
existing tools out there
and that to our agent to
announce its capabilities.
And we have a report generator.
The cluster is gonna be in
charge of creating an HTML
or markdown for us.
And definitely we
initialize the component.
So let me go one second
into the MCP client manager
'cause I wanna show you
what this is, really.
So few of you were not
familiar with the MCP.
So let me do a step back here.
I wanna explain a little bit what it is
so we're all on the same page, okay?
So MCP servers, those are tools.
So MCP stands for model
context protocol, right?
And those are servers that are in general,
vendored by companies like AWS
and they contain tools to
do work, as simple as that.
So, a way to imagine MCP tools is like,
the APIs for LLMs, okay?
So APIs are not that LLM friendly
because you have a bunch of parameters
but the LLM doesn't really know like,
it can do trial and error, right?
But MCP tools are meant
to be like use cases
that that agent and an
LLM can actually use
to fulfill a full job, okay?
And we're gonna see this again
when we're gonna build
our own custom tool.
So there are different tools.
So the idea here is
like, we don't want to,
like for example, we wanna
connect to CloudWatch
or CloudTrail application
signals, all those things.
Like, we don't want to have like a client
and make the agent to try
this API or this other API,
without really having the context
about what it's really doing.
That's what MCPs are for.
And today in this agent we're
gonna use three MCP tools,
the CloudWatch ones that
contains like metrics, logs,
alarms and so on.
Application signals for
monitoring your applications
and CloudTrail to see
logs into your account.
So to create MCP client with strands agent
is as simple as creating an MCP client
and parsing in as an argument,
the handle to the GitHub public
repository handle, right?
Which is AWS labs, CloudWatch MCP server,
AWS labs CloudWatch signal MCP server,
AWS labs CloudWatch MCP server, right?
And you're gonna find a lot of them
into the AWS labs repository.
In this case we're just
gonna use those three, right?
For our use case.
And then, these MCP clients.
So what it does is it
creates the MCP, sorry,
this MCP manager, it
creates those MCP clients
for the clients that we want.
And then it expose them with
a get all tool functions
where we return the tool
that is gonna be used within the agent.
So if we go back to the agent again,
we're gonna see here that we
initialize the components.
So effectively, we ask the MCP
manager, set up the clients,
the code that we just saw, okay?
So we use the AWS labs repository
to create the clients for
us and then create agent.
Okay, so now, before
I go and show you the,
literally two lines of code on
how you can create an agent,
I'm exaggerating a little bit.
I mean, there are technically two lines,
but there is a little bit around that,
I wanna explain to you one
thing that is very important
that we're doing here, right?
So one assumption we're making.
So you saw before in the slides
that Kevin showed us that,
to create an agent,
we're gonna need to
provide them some context
and we're gonna be interactive
with them, all right?
It's a two step process, really.
And this is exactly what we're
gonna do in the code, right?
So the first step is,
we're gonna create an agent
and set up like, make it
stick into some context
and then we're gonna prepare
a well written prompt
of what we're doing to actually invoke it.
At least like one thing,
like in this experience
of building this agent
that we also learned is,
writing a good quality prompt
for the agent is probably as
important as the code itself.
Because if you think about this,
like LLMs are general knowledge,
so the last thing that you
want is you run this agent,
it goes off, you know, maybe
find something for you,
maybe doesn't, but every time
it's telling you something
completely different.
You wanna really, almost
create a tunnel vision for it.
Like, you know about
everything in the world,
we're talking about like monitoring here.
So I want to restrict
your focus into monitoring
and do exactly what I'm
asking you to do, all right?
And you're gonna see a lot of that
into the code starting from now.
Okay, so the first step
is to create an agent.
As I said, we start with a system prompt.
We're gonna go back into
this prompt in a second.
I wanna show you how easy it
is to create an agent itself.
So to create an agent,
all you need to do is,
instantiate an agent class,
you're gonna pass the system prompt to it.
This is gonna be the initial context,
who the agent is, right?
Is the persona, like, who
are you impersonating.
And then you're gonna send
a list of tools to it.
So those are the tools
that an agent can use.
And you can see here HDP
requests, which you know,
basically means you can go
off the web and search stuff
and that's gonna be used
for postmortem search
and create CloudWatch alarm,
which is our custom tools
we're gonna see in a second.
And then there are MCP tools,
which are the tools that are
coming from the MCP manager.
So CloudWatch, CloudTrail,
and application signal.
So now, let's spend some time
just looking into this prompt
'cause I think it's really worth it.
So this is the context
that we set the agent on
and we say as the first thing,
you are an observability expert.
So we're really, remember
the tunnel visioning thing?
Like, we're saying to
the agent who you are,
what's the persona?
And we describe what are the capabilities.
So discovering, analyzing resources,
querying CloudWatch
metrics, CloudTrail event,
correlating data and so on.
You know, create CloudWatch alarm
using the tool that we
created for the agent itself,
and generate reports.
So now, one thing we're
gonna need to do is like,
if you're generic enough
in your prompt, right?
So you say like go off
and find the stuff for me.
Like, what does that mean for the LLM?
Like, it probably will go off
and do definitely something,
but we want to be precise, remember?
And so we want to tell the agent
how it's supposed to analyze
the AWS infrastructure.
And so we say, discover the resources
that exist in the region,
get infrastructure and
application metrics.
That's one way you can discover resources.
Like, don't go off and call
all the APIs for 250 services.
That's gonna be mental, it's
gonna take like days to run.
So one way you can avoid that,
go off into your observability artifacts,
you're gonna see metrics and logs
and that's how you can reverse engineer
the resources that you have, all right?
It's a shortcut for the agent,
but you see how important that is.
And then check for existing alarms
and look for pattern anomalies,
and then generate
actionable recommendation.
Now one important thing here is like,
we're saying to the agent context,
be conservative with alarm creation.
Remember, the agent will
do what we tell him to do.
So if you're not really
precise to the intent,
every time these agent will
run, we'll create alarms for us
because we're saying like, go off,
identify alarms that you
should create and create them.
But we don't want that
because you can end up creating
alarms that are very similar
maybe different configurations slightly,
data point or threshold to alarm,
but effectively the same semantic, right?
We don't want that, we want
alarms only on genuine gaps.
And that's exactly what we're saying here.
So be conservative.
We want those alarm for genuine gaps,
do not create duplicate or
near duplicate alarms, okay?
Then we ask him, please put some attention
into the resource type,
the key metrics, deep links
'cause we want that one step
click to the AWS console.
And we say what should be
focusing on, performance,
monitoring, customer
experience, customer impact
and optimization, cost, security.
That's how we found out the security scan
that we saw before.
And operational excellence improvement.
You know, all the thing about like,
hey, you have two gig of logs,
there is something you can do about it.
So now one interesting thing
here as we say is, hey,
we're also providing a create
CloudWatch alarm tool here.
So when you need to create those alarm,
that's the tool you're gonna need to use.
Don't go off and try to use a Boto client
or any API by yourself,
I'm gonna provide you a tool to do that.
Last but not the least,
be thorough, but concise.
So, okay, so at this stage
what we've done is go back here
and this is what our natural
observability agent is.
And at this stage, as first step,
we have the agent primed with the context.
He has the tools that he can
use, the MCP tools as well.
And now it's the next step
where we can actually go off
and run the analysis, all right?
Okay, cool.
So let's see how do we
run this analysis, okay?
So in this method here, you're gonna see
that there are two steps.
So one that says like, okay,
discover and analyze resources
and then generate the report, okay?
So let's go and look at how
we discover these resources.
So once again, here is the second step
where we are gonna be
interacting with the agent.
And I'm gonna skip the query for a second
'cause we're gonna see what it looks like.
But one thing that it's worth
to look at here is like,
how do we invoke the agent?
So invoking the agent is as
simple as, use agent as a method
and pass on the prompt that we wrote above
that we're gonna see in a second, okay?
So what that will do is,
we'll start the agent,
we'll send the prompt,
LLM will start working.
We'll go find out the things,
you know, using the tools
and everything like that.
And then we're gonna have results,
another language result from the agent.
And then we're gonna parse
it, we're gonna extract
and do some notification that
we're gonna see in a second.
Now, there are two things here
that are important to know this, right?
So the first is when we say,
MCP manager execute with client.
So if you go back here,
we have this function
that is maybe can be seen
as cryptic at the beginning,
but effectively, we have
a context manager here
that is connecting the
clients to the MCP server.
So remember, when we say
we have agent creations,
step number one, and agent
invocation is step number two.
So the idea here is, we
don't want the clients
to be connected for all
the lifetime of the agent
to the agent itself.
We want to connect the clients just
and only when we invoke them.
And that's the reason why
when we create the agent,
we invocate all tools.
So we prime the agent with
the client initialization,
but there is no connection
to the MCP server
and the client itself.
But then when we're actually
invoking the agent here,
we do agent query,
that's where we actually
need to execute with clients.
So effectively what we're
doing there is like,
we are saying to the initialized client,
connect to the MCP servers now
'cause I'm gonna need
to use the LLM, right?
Okay, cool.
So now, effectively this line
here is what you're seeing
in my terminal here, like
everything that is happening,
it's because the agent has been invoked.
And after this what we
do is we extract metric
from the response and then
we return the markdown
and the metric data.
So now, before we look into this,
I wanna go back into our prompt here
'cause you can see this prompt
is quite verbose, right?
And there's a reason for that.
So the prompt is what we're
asking the agent to do.
This is the core of the thing here, right?
So what should it do?
And so, the query is like,
analyze my infrastructure
and create the report,
that's what we want.
But before we go down, there is something
that it's worth to mention
and I'm stressing this a lot
because it's important,
which is, agent is stateless
unless you're gonna be fitting
with the previous run, right?
Which is something that we can do here.
But every time you're gonna run it,
it's gonna go off and do
stuff, we say this already.
And so, to create a report
that makes sense for humans,
you don't want them to
be random, all right?
And you're gonna find very quickly
if you try to create an agent yourself
without looking into
this code that the LLM,
what it's gonna do is, it's
gonna make like a few mistakes
and a few hallucination.
For example, it's gonna go off,
look at stuff and then
perhaps generate metrics
with what it thinks is the
right thing to show you.
Or creating sections that
are probably random, right?
It's not the one that you expect.
So it's not structured in
a way for a human to read
or for you to parse and send, for example,
to an agent pipeline, all right?
And we wanna fix all of
that with this prompt, okay?
So that's why it's very important.
So what we say here is like,
this is a multiple step job
so please, first thing is,
you're gonna need to discover resources,
find all the resources and
their relevant metrics.
There are compute resources,
database, serverless,
load balancers, storage
services and so on.
Then you're gonna need
to analyze the health
for each resource.
Go look into their metrics,
values, trends, health status,
active alarms, recent incidents,
performance and so on.
And then we need to generate deep links.
'cause the report is gonna
allow us to go into the console.
And then step four
is where we link to the postmortem, right?
So the public incidents.
And so, for any issue,
looking into postmortem up
for similar instance.
And don't do that just for the love,
go check if what you're seeing makes sense
with the publicly available incidents.
Don't force it, okay?
Because otherwise, it would just say like,
okay, so there is this
incident that maybe is related,
but there is really nothing to do with it.
So we're just saying like,
okay, so go look into that,
but only show up if it's really required.
Now, then there is the alarm
management section where,
so this is kind of interesting
because what we do here is
like, so think about this.
So the agent is gonna go into your account
and we need to get some recommendation
and perhaps creating some alarms, okay?
And we need to tell the agent,
how do you create alarms.
Like, how can you come up with
an alarm that makes sense?
You know, alarms are complicated, right?
You need to choose the right metrics,
or maybe set the metrics,
or a query to alarm on.
You need to find the right threshold.
Data point missing, how do you treat that?
Should the alarm be breaching or not?
And so, to solve all these
problem, what we do is,
we actually use MCP tools,
the CloudWatch MCP tools.
They have a tool that is called,
get recommended metrics alarms.
So this tool, it's vendored by AWS
and it's in the MCP tools servers.
And what it does is, it provides the LLMs
a kind of best practice
recommendation for alarming,
where you're gonna see
how different AWS services metrics relate
to a good alarms recommendation thresholds
and things like that.
And that's to prime the LLM and say like,
go check that first, right?
This is our best practice
alarm from AWS itself.
And after you do that,
check existing alarms,
you do comparison with best practices
and then only create new alarm
if there are gaps, as we say,
do not create duplicate alarms.
And then at some point we say
that you can actually use
the tool that we created
to create those alarms.
And then we ask next,
gimme a recommendation.
Include actionable
insights for performance,
cost monitoring and security.
So far so good.
So this is what we are
asking the agent to do.
But we can't stop there as we say
'cause the agent will output something
that is completely different every time.
So we need to parse this.
'Cause remember, we
want to create a report
and we want that report to be
as much stable as possible.
And that's why we say
to the agent, critical,
we're gonna need to structure
this report exactly this way.
We want an executive
summary two, three sentences
of what you found.
Active alarms and issues,
operational audit overview,
operational findings,
action recommendations
and relation to industry create incidents.
Remember that, like in our report,
that's exactly the sections
that we've been through, right?
So, and then another critical
requirement we're saying is,
don't come up with some
time series on your own.
Use the time series that
I have in CloudWatch,
use the MCP tool get metric
data and then return them back
so that I can actually
print my time series
like as we saw in the report.
And that's also very important.
'Cause what the LLM will do in general is,
it will analyze your
environment and stuff like that,
perhaps looking into some slides window
and then just make up values for you,
which is not what we want.
And to do that we also asking the agent
to provide a JSON into the output
where we have the list of the metric names
with the timestamps, the values, the unit,
and the brief description
so we can craft that into our report.
So perfect.
So we're back to here
where we run the agent
with this prompt.
And so from the markdown
result that you're gonna see
in the run here, you see, in the report
that is effectively like all
the section we talked about.
But what we need to do here
is, we need to parse the JSON,
for the metrics and, and all of that.
So effectively, we don't
want to show the JSON
into the HTMR report.
And so, that's why what we do is like,
we instruct this JSON, parse it
so that we can provide
to our JavaScript library
and we remove it from the markdown itself.
And that's effectively
what we're doing here.
And then we return the markdown
with all the content that we
found and the metric data.
So at this stage, if we go back up here,
that's where we analyzed our results.
And then at this stage we're
gonna generate the report.
So we generate this report
with the analysis result
and the metric data.
Now we can check this, sorry,
this method very quickly.
But in reality what we're doing here is,
we're getting the markdown and the JSON,
and then we're using Jinja template.
So in the template
folder, there is an HTML,
which has like CSS and everything else.
And effectively this is a Jinja template
where we are iterating over
the markdown and print it over,
and then use the JSON for the metrics
and generate the graphs that
you've seen before, okay?
So nothing special there.
So one thing I want to
talk about though is,
we saw how we invoked this agent,
but we also want to see how
we're instructing the agent
to create those alarms, right?
And that's where we
actually creating our tools.
So if you go into the tool folder,
there is an alarm tool file.
So this is the tool that is used
for the agent to create an alarm.
There are a few things
that are important here
to keep in mind.
So the first thing is, we
need to make our methods,
our Python code to be
exposed as a tool for MCP.
And that is as easy as
annotate with Art tool.
Art tool is a strands annotation
that you can just use on
any method that you want.
And that's about it.
You have your tool, right?
So at that stage you can actually take it
and fit it into the agent.
However, if you do that,
you gonna have a problem
pretty soon, right?
Because if you look into these
create CloudWatch alarms,
when you create an
alarm, as we said before,
it's not as easy as
like, just create a name,
maybe a metric and that's about it.
Like, there is a lot of configuration,
like there is alarm name, metric
name, namespace, and so on.
But most importantly,
there are like some configuration
here, like for example,
comparison operator greater than threshold
or statistic coverage,
that if we don't instruct
a agent on how to use them,
it would just go off and
try like average, AVG
or something else.
Or maybe it's like all over letters
and you're gonna have errors
from the client every time.
And then at some point the
agent will surrender and say,
I'm gonna try a different way, right?
We don't want that.
And that's why although
creating a tool is as simple
as adding this annotation,
again, giving the context
to the LLM is probably one
of the most critical thing
you're gonna need to do here.
And that's exactly what we do next.
So we say what this tool is about.
This is for the LLM to know
what this code is about to do.
And you can see we say,
this is for creating alarms,
they're a common use case
and then we talk about the arguments.
So we have alarm name, metric
name, namespace, and so on.
And see here, comparison operator.
Don't come up with some parameters
that probably won't work.
This comparator operator can
be greater than threshold,
less than threshold, greater
than or equals to threshold.
Same with statistic.
You can only use average, sum,
minimum, and maximum, right?
And this is important, this
is how the agent can go off,
use the tool in one shot, it works okay?
And then we say, what we returns back
and some examples of how to use the tool.
And then the tool itself is,
it's a mirror of our
CloudWatch alarms APIs.
So CloudWatch alarms provides an API
that is called put metric alarm
where you send all those parameters
and you just create an alarm.
Now this tool has been done on
purpose just for simplicity.
It's a mirror of the API.
But in reality, think about tools as like,
you pass only the parameters
that you really need
for your use case and then the
code will do the rest, right?
So you make it simple
for the LLM to use it.
And so here, all we are doing is,
we're using a Boto3 client for CloudWatch
and then we do some
validation and all of that.
And then we create a dictionary
with the alarm configuration
after validating parameters,
and then we call put metric alarm
with that configuration, right?
And this is exactly the same strategy
that is used into the MCP tools.
If you go off and open the AWS
labs code, you're gonna see
that they're kinda like
very similar to this.
Some are like a little bit
more complex, for example
there is a metrics insights tool,
which is the SQL language to
query metrics for CloudWatch.
So that's a little bit more complex.
So obviously you're gonna need
to build the SQL statements
and stuff, but most of the common tools
are kind of like a mirror of the APIs
or like, with some flavor of it.
So that's our agent.
Now, one thing I wanna show you quickly
is what our terminal
has output to us, right?
So you can see, I can go up above here
when the terminal was running
and you can see like all the
metrics that he found out.
So now I actually run
out of the space here,
but you can see there is an
application signal MCP server,
which is doing like
execute audit API, right?
So there are like multiple invocation
of the MCP servers here.
Like, or if we scroll
down, you're gonna see,
so this is still auditing,
still auditing, that's good.
So I'm gonna show you something there.
Yeah, so for example, like
publish metrics tools,
this is another MCP tools
where we're saying like,
okay, so building metrics insights query
for AWS EC2 CPU utilization.
So effectively this line here,
you see like we're using the MCP tools
that contains build metrics insights query
that I just talked about,
which is very complex
if you have to do all of
that just out of the box.
So I'm actually taking
all the CPU authorization
across all your fleet,
no matter how big it is,
and then getting your metrics out.
Like, one single query, you
get a lot of metrics back
and the agent can be instructed,
is there any EC2 instance
that is not performing well
or like an outlier into my system?
That's exactly how you're
instructing the agent
to behave, right?
And you know similar, log
group, describe log group,
I'm gonna see like, oh my
log group here, you know?
Or SLO tools and all of that.
And then at some point, all it does is,
as you can see here is,
based of my analysis,
this is my report.
And then, infrastructure consist
of 66 monitoring services
across ECS, EKS, Lambda and so on.
And high severity latency issues
identified in these other service,
no critical outage detected.
So effectively, this scan
has been fixed, right?
So this is a new run of the system.
I just wanna show you very, very quickly
how you can actually deploy
this in your environment.
So one of the idea here is,
you're gonna find an
agent setup Python file
that what is doing here is effectively,
what we want is this
agent not running manually
but perhaps run it
automatically based on an event
or even periodically, right?
And so, there are really
many ways to do this
and there are like a lot of talks here,
reinvent and talk about deployments.
So I'm not gonna go there,
but you can use CDK, Bedrock
core, really, you name it.
But one idea here is from an
observability standpoint is,
we will like from the agent
to be woken up before us.
So it'd be cool if all
the alarms that we have,
we have a duplicate of them
with more aggressive thresholds
in a way that can actually
trigger your agent to run.
So the idea is like,
the moment I get paged
at 3:00 AM in the morning,
the agent was already there
doing the work for me so
I can actually go off,
look at the report and see
what's going on, right?
And this is exactly what
these agents STEP.py is doing.
So again, we using the
MCP clients and all that.
There is a setup context prompt,
but then what we do here
is create CloudWatch alarms
with human alarms for operator
and trigger alarms for
preemptive assessment, all right?
And we created event bridge tools
to actually start up the agent itself.
So this is one way, clearly
that you can run the agent and deploy it.
Having said that, I think
I can pass it over to you
so we can actually show the QR code
if you wanna look at the repository.
Once again, please try
into pre-prod, all right?
Because as you can see,
the agent will go off
and do stuff, all right?
- [Kevin] Yeah, and we have
time for a question or two,
a few questions if anybody wants to ask
or talk about anything.
Let me come give you a
mic so we can hear you.
Go ahead.
- [Audience Member] Thanks.
MCP servers are notoriously
inefficient with token usage.
I'm just kind of curious how many tokens
this report took to run.
- [Kevin] So I don't think
we have the statistics,
but we did make sure
to carefully scope down
and be very specific with the context
because we ran into the same problem.
So I think it comes down
to being very specific
in terms of what you tell it to do.
Yeah, I don't know a
token count for the runs,
but we had the same
problem, so you're right.
So yeah, I think with
an observability tool
you really want to narrow
down what its scope is, right?
For us it was producing our report,
it wasn't doing everything.
It was just saying, give us an overview.
And I think when you keep the scope down,
you can also keep the token usage down.
- [Andrea] Yeah, and one thing
you've seen in the code is,
we took some shortcuts
to make sure that we
consume less token, right?
So for example, the metrics insights query
to understand if there is something wrong
with your EC2 instances,
that's one execution of one MCP tool only,
as opposed to go off into EC2 MCP tools
and find out all your EC2 instances
and then for each one of
those, go into metrics.
So there are some shortcuts like that
that can help you reduce number of tokens
quite significantly.
- [Kevin] Yeah, go ahead.
- [Audience Member] Sorry.
How do you execute the analysis?
Do you execute periodically
or each time we have an alert
we execute the whole workflow?
- [Kevin] Yeah, so you could do either.
So with our specific tool
we, you can see on GitHub
you can just execute it from the terminal
on a crown schedule if you wanted,
or you probably may have seen we came out
with something called Bedrock Agent Core,
where you can essentially put this
into a docker container image
and you can just deploy
it to AWS very easily.
So it could be listening
for an EventBridge event
or something like that.
Since we essentially were
just making a demonstration,
we kind of just, were running
it manually on a schedule,
but there's a lot of options that are new
and allow you to deploy
it and trigger it easily.
Yeah, go ahead.
- [Audience Member] So did you
test this workflow at scale?
For example, if we have a platform
with some hundreds of
thousands of alerts per day,
if we execute with a webhook, for example,
how have you imagined the platform behind
to support the toll, all this workflow?
- [Andrea] Yeah, well definitely.
So we did test this with a,
you know, not 100K scale.
That's definitely not.
You know, take the repository
as a demonstration of
what you can do, right?
But like if you have
like a high scale system
like 100K, that's exactly what
we were just saying before,
all the simplification that we have done.
Like, don't go off and discover sources.
There are some tricks
that you can do in AWS
especially when you talk
about observability,
like, use metrics insights, right?
So metrics insights is
like a 10K metric query.
So like for example,
if you have to analyze CPU
utilization for 10K metric,
it just takes like one
MCP invocation, right?
For one specific tool.
So like, definitely, 100K is a big scale.
So you're gonna expect to
perhaps like write tools yourself
to optimize for that scale.
But the trick there is like,
if you use those bulk MCP tools
or like bulk KPIs behind the scenes,
that's gonna make your life easier
when you go at that big scale.
- [Audience Member] So this
LLM model has a limitation,
it works only through Bedrock
or if I have my own open AI keys,
can I use this one with this repository?
- [Andrea] Yeah, it's a Python scoop.
Like, there is nothing
to do with Bedrock core,
it's just Python, pure python.
- [Kevin] The strands SDK,
you can put in an open AI
API key or any of them.
- [Audience Member] All models, okay.
- [Kevin] Whatever you're using, yeah.
- [Audience Member] Okay, thank you.
- [Audience Member] Is this on?
- [Kevin] Yeah.
- [Audience Member] Thanks for the talk.
Really, really cool stuff,
I just cloned the code.
I was curious about the,
if you ran into any issues
with structured outputs on any of this
since like the rendering,
it looks like it's taking a lot of data
that was generated as JSON from the model
and basically putting
that into the HTML output.
I've run into that before
and I was just curious
how you kind of dealt with that.
Maybe it was prompting
and that kind of thing.
And I know (indistinct).
- [Kevin] Yeah, so we
had to rely on templating
to do it, right?
So you're right, if you
essentially say like,
just make an output, right?
It's not there yet in our experience.
So we actually made our
template and we just fill it in.
It's just a standard Python
Jinja template where we can go
and fill in the sections that
it extracted from the fields,
from the log and metric data.
'Cause we had similar things
if you just kind of tell it
to do things like the graphs
would look all strange
or would use some strange
CSS or something like that.
So yeah, we had to be
more manual in that part
to get it to look proper, yeah.
About out time here.
And we will be standing outside
if you guys wanna ask us more questions.
But please take the survey.
Thanks for hanging out with
us and please take the survey,
it helps us a lot.
(audience applauds)
You guys, were awesome.
Clap for yourself, thank you.
- [Andrea] Thanks for joining us today.